Sal Khan: This is Sal
Khan of the Khan Academy
and I got these questions
from the Brazilian magazine,
Superinteresante, and I
don't speak Portuguese
that well but I assume it
means "super interesting"
so I hope I can meet their standards
and be at least somewhat interesting.
Then sent me these
questions and I'm just going
to give my best attempt to answer it.
Question number 1, and
actually, let me use
my pen tool Sal style
or Khan Academy style,
to mark what question I'm on right now.
Let's start with question number 1.
Do you see Khan Academy
as a modern compliment
to traditional education
or a resource that can be
adapted without any other tool?
Would that be the death of textbooks?
First, let's take the first part
because the second part's
a little controversial.
Do you see Khan Academy
as a modern compliment
to traditional education?
Yes, I do.
I think the ideal use
case for the Khan Academy
is someone has an amazing teacher,
and ideally amazing peers as well,
and they can go to a physical environment
and they can work with
their amazing teacher
and amazing peers, and what
happens from our material
is that they can watch
it at their own pace,
do the exercises at their own pace,
and they would get data on themselves
and their awesome teacher
and peers will get data.
Then they can use that
data to organize classrooom
time in a more interactive
way so that everyone
can really focus on helping
addressing everyone's problems.
At least in our minds, it
really liberates the teacher
to form lasting bonds and really mentor
and work with and solve the problems
that the students are
having with that material,
and it allows the students
to teach each other.
The second part of it, would
that be the death of textbooks?
This is an interesting question.
I guess it depends what you
view textbooks as being for.
Right now I think in most
classes textbooks play two roles.
One role is to introduce
you to the material
with the idea that, in a
lot of classes I've been in,
the professor would say,
"Hey, why don't you go home,
do some of the reading,
"that will be covered in lecture."
For that use case, I
think on-demand video,
whether it's Khan Academy
or other on-demand video,
is better than a lot of the texts
that can or cannot be
read by a lot of students.
It's much easier to get
it through on-demand video
than trying to parse through that text,
especially when you're
unfamiliar with the concept.
The other thing that a
textbook is for is practice.
That's where a textbook
is really different
than a traditional book is that it has
these practice problems in it.
What Khan Academy has is
practice problems as well,
but we're collecting data on them.
The teacher, the student
knows how they did,
how long it took them,
what they're having weakness
in or what they're strong in,
and the student gets instant feedback.
They know what they're understanding,
they know what they're not understanding.
They also get steps that we at least hope
explain to the student where
they might have messed up;
maybe they made a careless mistake
or maybe got the conceptual error
that they might have had trouble
and of course it's all tied to the videos.
Most textbooks right now
don't give that level
of data to the student or to the teacher
or the parents or anyone else,
and they don't even
give that much feedback.
They might have the answers
to half the questions
in the back of the book.
Some have a little bit more than that,
but not much more.
In those roles, we think
that on-demand video
with self-paced software
with feedback and data
can do a lot of those,
and it's even better
when it's free and it
doesn't weigh ten pounds.
With that said, I don't think textbooks
are going to completely disappear.
I think they're going to be
really useful as a reference.
I have a bunch of textbooks
that I'm staring at
right now on my shelf and I treasure them.
I think they'll be a
really useful reference.
It's not clear whether
you're going to have
generations and generations of students
having to buy the new
version of the textbook
every few years, especially for subjects
that are not changing on a regular basis.
It's also clear physical textbooks
are probably not going
to be the mainstream.
There's already a lot of
people doing e-textbooks,
but I assume that this
question is addressing
e and physical textbooks.
Question number 2:
If children study at home
and only go to school to do exercises,
teachers' presence may
become less important.
Would they have some
kind of a consultant role
instead of being someone
who explains the concepts?
I'll address the first part,
if children study at home
and only go to school to do exercises,
teachers' presence may
become less important.
This is something that I'll
disagree strongly with.
Imagine, if we were
doing it the other way,
imagine if the world was
a world where when kids
went to class, they had deep interactions
with their peers and, more importantly
or equally importantly, with the teacher,
where they went to a class,
the teacher knew who they were,
the teacher knew everything
about the student,
interacting with the student,
mentoring the student,
the teacher knew exactly
what the tripping points
were for the student,
how to phrase information
specifically for that student,
knowing what that student's context is,
and then all of a sudden I
were to go into that classroom
and say, no, teacher,
you have to stop doing
this mentorship, this direct
one-on-one instruction
with students, and what I
want you to do is not have
these conversations with students anymore,
and what I want you to do is
go to the front of the room
and I want you to give these lectures
that are essentially these one pace,
one size fits all lecture.
Really it'll be essentially
the same lecture that every
teacher in the country's giving
and that you've given years before.
That would be making the
teacher less important
because you would have
taken them as a human being,
as someone who understands what's going on
with the student, kind of the doctor
for the student's knowledge,
and then you would be
turning them into a broadcast mechanism.
We're doing the exact opposite.
Right now, unfortunately,
a lot of teachers
want to be that mentor.
A lot of the teachers
want to use class time
for interaction and
creativity, but right now
they have to move the entire
class at the same pace,
and they have to give that lecture,
many times with very little
interaction with the students.
What we're saying is, no, that can happen
at the student's own time and
at the student's own pace,
and then the teacher just
becomes, every minute of time
with the teacher just
becomes this valuable nugget.
Several of the classes
that we're piloting,
one of the teachers is making a point
to spend 15 minutes one-on-one
with every student per week, at least.
I can remember years that I went by
never getting 15 minutes
one-on-one with the teacher.
That happens to many, many students.
We think, if anything,
it's making the teachers
far more important.
They're forming bonds.
They have to have a better grasp of all
of the information now
because you have students
working at their own pace.
It's really taking them up the value chain
because they're no longer giving
the same lecture year in and year out.
Then the second part of the question,
would they have some
kind of a consultant role
instead of being someone
who explains the concepts?
What I would say is that they're still
explaining the concepts, but they're
explaining the concepts
given all of the information
that they now have about the student.
Given the fact that
that student has already
maybe watched our videos,
has already done exercises,
the teacher can now act on the data
coming from those videos
and those exercises.
Once again, I think the teacher
has moved up the value chain.
They're now more valuable for that student
than they were as a pure lecturer.
Question number 3:
When children have the freedom to study
by themselves, at home,
surrounded by other appeals
such as internet, social medial
and also the possibility
to just ignore the lessons,
isn't it too much confidence
in their passion for learning?
Don't you think some
discipline is necessary
to make them study instead
of doing anything else?
There's a couple of
ways to think about it.
Right now in a traditional classroom,
you have mostly lecture going on,
maybe with a little bit of other things,
and then all of the problem solving,
all of the homework, happens at home.
I agree, some students might not have
the motivation to do it at home,
and we see a lot of kids
skipping the homework.
Even the ones that do have the motivation
might not have the help.
So in my mind, where the
real learning happens
is actually when you're trying
to do the problem solving.
What's happening right
now is a lot of students
are skipping out on the problem solving,
on doing the homework,
either because of distractions
or because they have no one to help them.
Then they all go to a room together
where they're in the same room,
but they're all passively
listening to a lecture.
We think if you had to drop one thing
from that equation, make sure
the problem solving occurs.
Make sure that the teacher
sees students do problems.
Don't put that out for homework where
it may or may not happen.
If you had to, and we
wouldn't advocate this,
but we think if you had to pick
between doing homework and lecture,
which one do you skip, frankly
the lecture is, I think,
the one that's more optional.
In fact some students, and we've seen this
in some of our pilots,
you show them enough
examples or their peer can
teach them how to do something,
they don't necessarily even
need to see the lecture.
If they see a few examples
of it, that's enough.
Maybe they'll go back
and watch the lecture
for more depth or for more
intuition on the subject.
With that said, on top
of that, we don't want
to just completely let it
up to the student's judgment
and have the teacher guessing
when they come to class
the next day whether or not the student's
watched lectures or did
some of the problems.
That's why we're so focused on the data.
That's why we're so focused on right now
the teacher does get
a real-time dashboard.
In a traditional classroom, the teacher
just sees who turned in their homework
or who did the homework,
and who knows if they
copied it from another student.
They don't know how long
it took the students
to do the homework, whether
they got it right or wrong.
They don't know what time of
day they did the homework.
Now, the teacher will know everything.
Now the teacher knows what
videos the student watched.
Where did they even pause the videos?
What videos did they have to repeat?
They'll see the spread of where
every student in the class is.
They'll see what problems
the kid actually did,
how long it took them, when
they did those problems.
Early on when I was doing
this, I saw one of my cousins
was doing all of their
problems at 2 in the morning.
That, by itself, was
probably more information,
that they were awake at 2 in the morning,
then the fact that they were even getting
some of those problems wrong.
That's something that a human being
can then intervene in.
Going back to the too much confidence, no.
Now we're arming everyone
with a lot more data,
so it's de-risking just
putting it all on the student
to do everything at home.
Question number 4:
Let me scroll down a little bit.
And the possibility to learn in your own
wouldn't contribute to
isolate shy and misfit kids?
Once again, complete opposite.
Some people might be
surprised to hear this.
I was actually very, very shy,
especially in elementary
and to some degree
in middle school, and I
felt very, very isolated
in my classrooms.
When I was in a classroom with 30 kids,
even when I had a question, I
was afraid to raise my hand.
I think this is true of
many, many, many kids.
You don't want to embarrass
yourself raising ...
It's usually the most outgoing kids
who are willing to raise their hand,
usually the two or three
most outgoing kids.
I was never willing to do that.
If I didn't understand something,
I would just put it on myself to go home
and try to struggle with it somehow.
I had my sister who often
helped me with things.
But I felt very isolated.
Also, because I was shy,
there would be 30 kids
in the room, but I really only knew
maybe 5 of them well, maybe
because they sat near me.
I would sit in class, and
this is even true in college.
I used to sit in classes in college
where there was 100 people in the room,
and I only knew 2 of them.
I would sit in that room
for the whole semester
and I would never get to meet any of them
the way that a traditional model works.
And, frankly, the professor
never knew who I was.
That even happened in
some of my elementary
and middle school and high
school, where I don't really
think the teacher knew who I was.
What we're saying is the exact opposite.
What we're saying is now
you're using the class time
for the students to actually
interact with each other.
If you look at these
pilots that we're running
in Los Altos, you have all of the students
interacting with all of the students.
You don't have these little cliques
where certain kids only hang out
with other kids and ignore the rest;
you have them all helping each other.
It actually gives an
outlet for the shy kids,
maybe the shy kids who
perform a little bit
better academically, to
actually gain confidence
by teaching their peers, their peers start
to respect them more, not just as this
shy kid who happens to do good at school,
but, wow, that kid helped me.
We're seeing way more interaction.
There's no kid who's just
hiding during the lecture
and just pretending to
understand the information.
Everyone is interacting.
The teachers are interacting
with the students.
The students are
interacting with each other.
So we think it's the exact opposite.
We think we're taking the isolation that
they shy kids are feeling right now
and we're having them actually interact
with each other in a human
experience in the classroom.
Question number 5:
Do you believe that some
old fashion thinkers
just don't accept an education system
that is supposed to be cool?
Not 100% sure how to answer that question.
I guess the assumption here is that what
we're proposing is cool.
I think it is.
I think any time there's change,
there will always be resistance,
and I think that's a healthy thing.
People should actively question things.
No one should adopt something just
because it's supposed to be cool
or just because it sounds cool.
You shouldn't just accept
it because it sounds cool,
and you also shouldn't just
reject it because it sounds cool.
The reality is that you really
should see whether it's working,
and you should see whether it's working
on multiple levels subjectively.
How are the teachers and
the students liking it?
How is the energy level?
You should also look at it objectively.
How is their performance changing?
There definitely are knee-jerk
reactions against new things
and there are knee-jerk
reactions for new things.
Neither of those are the
best ways to approach it.
You really should just have an open mind
to anything and see if it really works.
Question number 6:
How has the acceptance to Khan Academy,
I would assume, been in the United States?
Has Bill Gates' support helped to open
some conservative doors?
We're still in the early days.
Khan Academy, once again, it started as
a very grassroots things.
I started it for my cousins.
It was adopted not because of a governor
or the president told people to adopt it,
or a superintendent did.
It was adopted because
students chose to use it,
students on their own,
students who happened
to bump into it on the
internet found it useful.
So it was a very grassroots thing.
Only later, once we had
significant traction
and I had been doing this for 5 or 6 years
did it start to get on the radar of some
fairly prominent people,
many of those who have
supported us now, including Bill Gates
and Google and others.
In terms of the acceptance
of the Khan Academy in the U.S.,
the people who have chosen to
adopt it naturally like it.
They have made the decision to use it.
We haven't forced it on anyone else.
I think that's a really important thing
because I think when anyone
forces anything on anyone
they tend to not like it.
So far the acceptance has been very good
and we've had really
fascinating experiences
and tremendous results with
the pilots that's chose
to adopt it if we talk
about the formal setting.
If you're thinking about
the informal setting,
the students who are just
using it independently,
I encourage anyone to
go to our YouTube page
or our Facebook page and
just read the commentary
from students, and even
ask them questions,
contact them, and see how it's helped them
and I think you'll see,
at least we like to think,
it's profoundly effecting
a lot of students
in the U.S., and the world, frankly.
The question has Bill
Gates' support helped
to open some conservative doors?
You know, I think that's a mixed answer.
I think it's definitely given validation
within certain circles.
I think people in Silicone
Valley really respect
that Google is behind us,
Bill Gates is behind us.
These are obviously groups and people
who are obviously intelligent,
who've obviously been successful,
who obviously understand
what a math and science
education is for, who are
almost the examples of ...
The people at Google understand there's
no better application of math and science
than what Google has done
or what Bill Gates has done
or what other people in
Silicone Valley have done.
That's definitely validation.
Whether it opens conservative doors or not
is not clear because I
think Bill Gates has also
been doing other things.
He's very active in the Charter movement.
He's been pushing for other things.
There are some people
who react against that
and they might be tempted
to throw us in the same bag.
Us, personally, we try not
to take an opinion on that.
We want to be useful for
anyone, in any organization.
We're not taking a political stance there
but I think because Bill Gates really is
one of our biggest supporters,
some groups are more receptive to it
and some groups are less receptive to it.
Overall, I definitely think
it's been a huge positive
because I think the
parents and the students
view it as a huge plus when
someone whom they respect
think so highly of it and uses it himself
and uses it for his kids.
Question number 7:
Has Khan Academy ever been contacted
by some Brazilian school or company
interested in adopting its methods?
I can't say no totally.
We've had a lot of contact
with people from Brazil
and we are actively
translating the video content
to Portuguese, so we've
had contact with Brazil.
We're not doing any
formal pilots in Brazil.
I wouldn't be surprised if
some students or teachers
are using it independently.
In fact, I'm sure some students are.
Teachers can use what
we're doing in Los Altos
on their own, but we don't have any formal
pilots in Brazil right now.
Question number 8:
Besides the positive testimonies
from Los Altos' teachers,
do you have some numbers
that could measure
how Khan Academy has
helped students to develop?
Some numbers that could help us compare
traditional education to
your system's performance.
The simple answer is,
yes, we do have numbers.
This is why Los Altos has decided to go
district-wide with this
in the 5th and 6th grade.
Actually, let me pause the video
and let me get you some of those numbers.
Hold on one second.
You asked for data, so
here's data that I got.
We have other data, but
this one piece of data
is probably the most compelling
that really convinced Los Altos.
It's not a rigorous study.
We're going to be doing more
rigorous studies this year
with larger data sets and
in a more controlled way,
but we obviously had all of the anecdotal
higher energy in the classroom,
kids were more engaged,
the teachers loved it, but
we wanted to see real data.
This is actually what we saw
out of the 7th grade pilot.
I want to be clear,
these 7th grade classes
were considered developmental classes,
kids that weren't tracked
with the normal students;
they were held back, they weren't
performing at grade level.
This shows how they performed
at their district
standardized exam in 2010.
You can see that the best students here,
you had 23 that were proficient,
then you had 47 that were basic,
23 that were below basic,
and then you had 6 that
were far below basic.
Don't get this light blue confused
with this dark blue over here
because they're saying
very different things.
This is far below, so
this right over here,
they're not doing well,
far below basic, this 6.
The same students,
after doing Khan Academy
for about 6 or 7 months,
and once again it's hard
to separate how much ...
Courtney Caldwell, who's the teacher here
is just an off the charts awesome teacher
so it might be due to her
as well, what we've seen.
She herself expressed
that the energy level
that she saw in the class is very unusual
for especially a class that is at this
developmental stage.
These are the results from
this year's standardized exams.
There's no longer any
students in this group
that are far below basic.
In fact, there are now 6
kids that are advanced.
Just to be clear, these
are kids that have, now,
leapfrogged their peers who
are not placed in this class.
Normally when you're
tracked into a slower class,
that's usually the end
of your math career.
You're usually just going
to drift further and further
behind the other students.
These students after half
a year actually did better
than many students who weren't
placed into the slower class.
Then you have many, many more students
who are now proficient.
The basic, you still have 47, but you have
so many more who are
proficient or advanced.
Then you have no students
that are far below basic.
In 12% of the pilot, students
moved from below basic
to proficient, and 6% moved
from far below basic to basic.
There's a general trend where
people just moved forward.
This was a big one.
We have other data and we're hoping to get
a lot more data this year.
Once again, not a rigorous
study, so not something
that we can publish in
a scientific journal,
but that, with all of
the anecdotal evidence,
made Los Altos feel pretty good
and made us feel pretty good.
We don't consider this a done deal.
We consider ourselves, we're just in
the first inning and we have to constantly
improve this thing so that we can get
even better results next year,
and then the year after that.
Question number 9:
Do you believe children
should have the opportunity
to use other new technologies in school,
such as mobile phones,
iPods, and podcasts?
I think it's like everything.
If it's used in a proper
context, yes, if it's helpful.
If it's not helpful, maybe no.
We should have an open mind about
what helpful is or what it isn't
and just try things out
and adjust accordingly.
Question 10:
Are films the new books?
Do you think that a
culture focused on images
has contributed to the
notion that books are boring?
Films, on some level, they are,
even before Khan Academy shows up,
films have always been a form of book.
People still like to read the
book and then watch the film.
The books give you more
depth, give you more nuance,
but the films are still fun.
I don't think it's a
culture focused on images
that has contributed to the
notion that books are boring.
I think there are books that
are amazing and fascinating,
and some of my best experiences in life
are from reading some
of those amazing books,
but there are books that are boring.
It doesn't hurt if we can find a medium
that is less boring.
I think it really depends
from case to case.
And I don't think it's
just this generation.
I think if you'd taken any generation
and if you'd given them
something that's less boring
or a better way or a more intuitive way
or a more approachable way
to understand something,
they would have found
it equally compelling.